- And in a year where
everything has been turned
absolutely upside down, we've been working
to come up with new ways to
stay connected with each other.
Nothing's better than
seeing people in person,
even if they can't make it to the studio.
So this season I've been
catching up with some
of our favorite and some
of your favorite stars,
car-to-car with our Drive-INterviews.
♪ Drive-INterview ♪
- You just must have so much fun.
I bet there's wine involved.
These jingles are so amazing.
Oh, my God.
So most recent, and get
it, Drive-INterviews.
We're so clever.
Most recently I saw Sarah Michelle Gellar,
and it was so much fun.
Check it out.
(upbeat instrumental music)
(car horns honking)
Hey.
- [Sarah] Well hello.
- What's up, Sarah?
- Come here often?
- I actually do.
I mean I'm, if my family asks,
I'm shopping for school supplies.
But what are you doing?
- If my daughter knew
I was here, forget it.
Although clearly I'm from New York,
because look how I parked at a drive-in.
- Yeah, but clearly it'd be awesome though
'cause your car is big enough
you could pretty much sit in the back.
(Kelly laughing)
- Relax.
- So your car is sweet.
- I know, right?
- So what was your first car?
- Oh, my first car was not this sweet.
I had a green Chrysler LeBaron.
- That's pretty sweet.
- I don't know about that.
And I remember everyone said
when you first like get a job
in Hollywood, don't buy a new car,
'cause it's the kiss of death.
And on the first season of "Buffy,"
everybody else got new cars,
and I'm still second season,
riding in in my green
Chrysler LeBaron convertible.
So finally midway through the
second season, I was like,
"I'm done, I'm getting a new
car," but it worked out okay.
- Oh my gosh, I love that.
That's still sounds
like a pretty sweet car.
So is it true that y'all,
I know a lot of people
are doing road trips
because of COVID.
You and Freddy, did y'all
bond over a road trip?
Is that what I hear?
- We did, 'cause I had just
gotten my driver's license
when we did "I Know What
You Did Last Summer."
And we filmed in a really tiny town.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh, you've
been together forever.
- Forever.
I'm 100.
- You're (laughing)
- And I had not yet, wasn't
used to taking big, long drives.
And we were doing a movie
about killing someone
on the side of a road,
and you just get your driver's license,
you don't really like
doing long road trips.
And the only gym that I could go to
because I wasn't 21 was like an hour away.
And so he would drive me
into town for the hour drive,
and then he would like run
errands while I went to the gym
and then he would pick me up.
And so we would talk on the road.
- Oh my gosh, I love road trips.
So when was the last time
you were at a drive-in?
- I went to my first drive-in last Friday.
- Your first one?
- My first drive-in.
We had a birthday party,
a socially-distanced, birthday party.
And we made a parking lot
into a drive-in movie theater.
It was my first experience.
- You are the coolest parents ever.
- I didn't throw the party.
I went to the party.
- Okay, well--
- To clarify it.
- Wow.
- I'm not that cool.
- I'm like, that's amazing,
and such a smart idea.
- Isn't it a great idea?
So we're doing my daughter,
we're doing a socially-distant backyard.
My best quaran purchase,
I like to ask people
what their like ridiculous
quaran purchase is,
and my quaran purchase was
a backyard movie screen.
- Oh, mine was a bounce house.
- Oh yeah, that's a good one.
I also bought an inflata-bull,
which is actually like a bull riding thing
that goes in the pool.
- Which sounds awesome for adults as well.
So have your kids seen "Buffy?"
- We just started.
I had never thought to show it to them.
And they asked during quarantine,
and they said, "We were trying
to like find shows to binge."
And I was like, "Okay."
I didn't even know if they'd be into it,
but they are like so into it,
except I'm the world's biggest
disappointment for them
because they'll always ask questions,
and I'll be like, "I don't remember.
"I'll have to text someone and ask."
And they think they know it
better than I do at this point.
- Oh my God, I loved it.
It made me want to be a ninja.
I just wanted to be
able to be like, "Waa!"
You were always kicking butt.
- My son actually thinks
that I'm cool now.
- I bet, seeing cool, there you go.
I'm still not cool to mine. (laughing)
So wait, tell me about
your work for Myopia.
It's a personal cause, and
I heard I heard about it.
- Yeah, it's been really
an interesting time for me
because I have never done that
much schooling with my kids.
And I noticed when we started
on socially-distant Zoom school
that my son was blinking a ton,
and it turned out that it was because
as these kids are on these devices
and they're like looking constantly,
they're becoming more and more myopic,
which is basically just nearsightedness.
- Wow.
- So I partnered up with CooperVision
to be able to tell parents about this
because I think it's
something that we don't know.
- Yeah.
I was nearsighted.
God, I couldn't see,
oh, anything.
- It's so hard.
And then they're looking at the screen
and they're trying to focus and it's just,
it's so hard for them.
- And isn't it funny, we're always like,
"Get off the screen," and
then the pandemic hits,
and we're like,
"Be on the screen!"
- "Be on that screen
"eight hours a day."
- Yeah, yeah.
- And then give them homework.
- I know, that's one of the worst.
My kids are so not
excited about this year.
Well, it was nice to see you.
- It was such a pleasure
to see you.
- Yes.
You have such a rad car.
- Yeah, you know what?
I do too, thank you.
- You're like even cooler
now, how is that possible?
- Your ride is pretty sweet.
- You need to like take a picture
and then rub it into Freddy.
- I already did that.
- Well, see you next time, girl.
- Bye!
(crowd applauding)